so many people send me messages oh
someone called you a wahhabi someone
called you a Sufi someone said you're a
salafi someone said you're a debandi
someone said you're a barvi some of
these names I don't even know what they
mean to be honest with
you I was waiting for the day they said
someone call you a chocolate man because
that's more that's true you
know and the same Victorious sect is
only one am the rest of of the 72 sect
of misguidance going towards
destruction so one must take care and
precaution to this affair and this is
something that we
find Troublesome in these times
where the
people where the people many people
going towards destruction you find them
going towards these callers of
misguidance whether it's in YouTube or
Instagram or other than that from these
social media Outlets we find many people
going towards uh the people of
Destruction and this is uh uh what we
find in this
[Music]
time a prophet will come on the day
judgment and there will be one or two
followers or few followers and another
Prophet will come without any followers
and he's a
prophet 950 years and only few followers
Allah described only a few followers
that believed him
and having many followers
is uh a sign that he is trying to please
or the person is trying to please the
masses meaning that he uh compromises
many aspects of the dean in order to
accept many yeah accept the many
followers but the people of you find
that they few they are few and they're
strangers
a chocolate it become like a
chocolate chocolate it becomes like a
chocolate everybody loves chocolate
[Music]